Wow so how did we get here
[Music]
hi everyone I'm Mindy Kaling I'm reese
witherspoon Woodbury and you're watching
pretty 52 so how did we get here
gosh a long journey we came to London
but let's let's keep it short what do
you think was the most pivotal moment
that changed your life and got you where
you are today I dropped out of college
Wow yeah and it was scary because I
thought I couldn't afford to pay the
tuition and then not work so then I went
to go be an actress and then I got this
job they called me and said okay after
you finish that movie do you want to go
do this other movie and I had to make a
decision to go back to school or start
my career and I thought because I was
gonna go into medicine I wanted to be a
doctor oh and I made a chant I said okay
well if I do this movie and it's
successful then I will continue being an
actor hopefully okay what was the most
pivotal moment for you for me it would
be leaving Baltimore at the age of 29
going to Chicago to host my own show
when everybody said you're gonna fail in
Chicago and I thought well if I fail
I'll just go into advertising or
something I don't know but I now learned
as much as I can learn in this
particular spot and that's how I always
knew it's time to move if I hadn't moved
to Chicago I wouldn't be sitting here
with y'all that's a really good point
cuz I think people get stuck
I always think life has many chapters it
does and they need to look different and
you need to have different jobs and
different adventures for each chapter
what advice would you give your gun
yourself I had a moment three years ago
where I was having a lot of self-doubt
and I was about to start this movie
called wild where I have to be all alone
in the movie and I don't talk very much
in the movie which was scary to me and I
did this exercise with a therapist and
she said to your older self is gonna
talk to you at this time and she said
what would you say and I it just
completely freed me up and I said it's
gonna be okay you're gonna be successful
and it gave me courage to do something
scary to tell myself that it would be
okay to try something scary I would say
to myself relax just relax it's gonna be
okay
lean into who you are and stop worrying
about what everybody else thinks because
look at how much time all of us as women
people spent worrying about what other
people
we're thinking of us somebody said
something smart to me that there's the
human capacity to think of another
person it's about 30 seconds so if
you're spinning there and you're going I
see the dumbest thing is that the
dumbest thing usually the person that
you you're so worried that they're
judging you is going I need a sandwich
very freeing reader you're so worried
that they're judging you but they're
actually just thinking they're thinking
about themselves I would give mind about
relationships because I think the rush
is that I had when I was like 12 13 14
15 through high school were the most
passionate feelings I've ever had in my
life even now even in the great loves
that I've had in my 30s in my 20s could
not muster up the amount of our jury
that I had as a kid and I would love to
tell the person back then you will not
even remember their names of your
crushes yeah you have when your lesson
because you think here I became so
fixated on romantic love because it was
so alien to me and there's plenty of
time that's why I have such respect for
young love because when you're young you
don't have the perspective to know that
you're not gonna remember his name you
feel it so deeply so powerfully and so
everybody is saying oh that'll pass I
try not to say that I go just go ahead
and feel it feel it give people
permission to feel it because when
you're young you feel things stronger
yes who has been the biggest influence
on your career and why we used to
influence on my career would be a guy
that nobody knows James Dennis wanted it
was general manager of the ABC station
in Chicago that hired me to do this show
called am Chicago and I had been
previously hired in Baltimore and the
moment I got hired they wanted to change
me they wanted me to be thinner they
wanted my nose to be different they
wanted me to actually have plastic
surgery they asked me to change my name
they asked me though and so when I was
hired by Dennis Swanson the very first
day when he said we want you to do this
job I said well you know I'm overweight
and you know I have this throw and I
have them he said and I'm looking at you
and I'm overweight too and we don't want
either change a thing we just want you
to be yourself so he gave me permission
at the time there was this giant of a
talk show host named Phil Donahue and he
was like the king of talk and I he said
we know you can't beat Phil Donahue we
just want you to be yourself
and the first day I was on the air beep
Wow why that happened because you gave
me permission to do so yeah because I
wasn't trying to be Phil Donahue what
relief
what a relief and so that was changed my
career finish it once and saying we just
want you to be yourself is it amazing
yeah but that's how anybody gets to be
successful is finding a way to lean into
your own frequency thanks for watching
2052 thanks for watching pretty 52
thanks for watching pretty pity do you
swear I've done this for